right now puberty is telling you to step
on the gas if your vagina was a car what
would it be a ferrari stays covered up
and completely untouched in the garage
mine would definitely be a transformer
you think you know her boom autobots pop
out i feel like if you're following the
metaphor that means you have crabs what
we finally tried reverse cowgirl and
amazing right it wasn't that great for
me but i feel like it looked cool i was
a horse [ __ ] and i haven't even had
my first kiss
oh [ __ ] look at hunter who plays hockey
in a cardigan he's like an athletic
librarian you know sonny's throwing a
party really love a good high school
party with the liquors and the touching
all the other stuff drugs
it's a big night for you inviting your
crush
partying
and drinking i feel so stimulated is
this what white privilege feels like hey
good choices
oh [ __ ]
lupe i
had
sex
what you banged your crush at your own
party you are my hero
oh god i was peeing and a condom
fell out
what
i'm kind of full of goo let's get the
point b pill is there an alternative you
mean a plan b
sorry but i declined to offer you the
plan b bill have a nice day
let's go to planned parenthood in rapid
city hey do you realize this is our
first official road trip
where are we on here what do these red
lines mean this really it needs a
pension zone
i hate to tell you but planned
parenthood is probably closed for the
night my 24-hour window is closing
so the condom just fell out
i've been there
[Music]
it's like a really small chance it might
be pcp
[Music]
this